two bad batch episodes in one week was
an excellent may the fourth gift from
star wars hq and the second installment
of the disney plus series is full of fun
references from the galaxy far far away
here are the small details you may have
missed in episode 2 cut and run
in many ways the star wars universe is
actually pretty small
while there's an entire galaxy's worth
of star systems out there star wars
stories tend to revisit the same worlds
over and over
the salukimai system the setting for the
second episode of the bad batch is no
exception
die hard star wars fans probably knew
that the bad batch was headed to
seleucum before the episode even aired
at the end of the bad batch pilot hunter
tells tech to plot a course for j19
that's a designation for the sector
which contains seleumi as revealed in
the star wars the clone wars episode
grievous intrigue
in that episode the commander of the
separatist droid army general grievous
captures jedi master eth koth
and takes him to seleucum i forcing
obi-wan kenobi anakin skywalker and
master adigalia to mount a rescue
mission
the jedi save cough but grievous crash
lands on salukimi
setting up the events of the next
episode the deserter in which we meet
cut and sue for the first time
it's not the last time we'll see
selukimai in the star wars timeline
either
in revenge of the sith salukimai is
where the jedi stasa lee is killed while
on her speeder bike following the
issuing of order 66.
so cut sue and their family aren't new
characters but their family farm has a
new look
in the deserter captain rex injured in
an attack shelters with the clone
deserter and his wife
in exchange for their hospitality rex
promises not to rat cut out and leaves
them to live their lives once he's
healthy
clearly that happened a while ago
because when the bad batch reunites
viewers with a la quaine farm
things look very different cut now has a
grey streak in his hair
indicating how much he's aged his
children have grown as well
the farm itself is now surrounded by a
wire fence and other security measures
including battle droid sentries likely
cobbled together from pieces of those
destroyed during the deserter
say what you will about the empire but
if nothing else it's very efficient
presumably cut and run takes place right
after palpatine issued order 66 and
transformed the republic into the
galactic empire
jedi bodies were still being hauled out
of kamino when the bad batch returned
and they fled almost immediately
afterwards but by the time the clones
get to salukemai the imperial
machine is already up and running you
can see this best when kut and hunter
head into town to get the lay of the
land
instead of the eight-pointed emblem of
the galactic republic all government
buildings now sport the six-spoked
imperial crest
the language has been updated too the
kiosk where the clone troopers issue
chain codes and shuttle tickets has been
renamed the imperial information station
those credits won't do you any good
without a chain code
new galactic policy the imperial chain
codes that cause cut sue and the bad
batch so much
trouble are pretty new additions to star
wars canon 2. they were first mentioned
in the pilot episode of the mandalorian
and have only actually popped up on
screen
once in episode 14 of the mandalorian
boba fett shares his chain code with din
jaren in order to prove
ownership of his best gar armor the bad
batch aren't the only clones who escaped
order 66.
in the final episodes of the clone wars
series finale ahsoka tano disables clone
captain rex's inhibitor chip freeing him
from emperor palpatine's mind
control in turn rex helps ahsoka escape
the clone army and fake her death paving
the way for her return in star wars
rebels and the mandalorian
that's why when rex gets name dropped in
cut and run it's a big deal
rex is a major figure in star wars lore
not only was he anakin skywalker second
in command during the clone wars but he
ended up fighting for the rebellion
thanks to the heroes of star wars rebels
he even fought on the forced moon of
endor helping the rebels destroy the
second death star and bringing the
empire to its knees
however we know absolutely nothing about
what rex was up to between the clone
wars and star wars rebels leaving a huge
gap in his history
one that the bad batch looks like it's
going to fill not only has rex been
sighted in trailers for the bad batch
but cut and sue mentioned that the bad
batch are only a day or so behind it
expect rex to show up sooner rather than
later check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite star wars stories are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]